dans l'impossibilité de s'entendre avec
ses partenaires européens sur la
construction d'un avion de combat commun
la france on le sait a décidé d'en
construire un seul loin de se désoler de
l'échec du projet européen les
constructeurs français se réjouissent
voici vous êtes les premiers à les voir
les premières images sur ce projet
appelé rafale car bavay de l'ex futur
avion de combat européen on ne
connaissait jusque là que cette
silhouette présentait d'ailleurs au
salon du bourget et bien voici
maintenant d'autres documents que nous
sommes en mesure de vous montrer ce soir
tout d'abord la capacité d'emport des
armements selon les différentes
configurations d'emploi supériorité
aérienne appui tactique ou pénétration
et puis voici un autre document la
thermographie de la partie avant de
l'appareil qui démontre ses capacités
d'absorption thermique et puis surtout
cette photo pour la première fois la
carte de l'utilisation des matériaux
nouveaux carbone psp kevlar titane et
lithium
nous sommes aussi en mesure de vous
dévoiler la configuration du cockpit
conception révolutionnaire avec ses
manches latéraux et ses écrans de
visualisation qui remplaceront les
différents voyants et les quatre ans et
puis enfin ce diagramme très éloquent
qui décrit l'optimalisation du rafale
toute cette suprématie technologique
l'aéronautique française aurait été
obligé de la partager
dans le cadre du programme européen on a
l'impression que vous êtes un peu
soulagés ici parce que le projet rafale
va rester en france donc vous allez
garder la maîtrise d'oeuvre
vous n'aurez pas à partager votre savoir
faire oui je veux dire que
la france je crois depuis des années
était fier d'être capable de mener à
bien elle même un avion complet un
mirage 2000 et à 99 5% pratiquement dix
ans à 100% français sa cellule et
françaises ces moteurs sont français ces
équipements sont français y compris les
équipements les plus sophistiqués et
donc c'est le résultat du travail de
toute une industrie pendant des années
et d'avoir atteint ce stade qui est le
résultat d'une volonté politique
industrielle de faire complètement un
avion de ses rafale dassault devrait en
vendre 330 à l'armée française et
peut-être pas loin du triple à
l'exportation des recettes en tout cas
que dassault n'aurait pas à partager
avec d'autres partenaires